[Music]
Toronto Mayor Rob Ford really is in
rehab he is in rehab no one knows
exactly where all we're being told is
it's somewhere in North America now I
think I speak for everyone when I say
I'm just happy mayor Ford is finally
getting the help he so desperately needs
what what's that really you're kidding
really I've just been told pretend that
with very few words I've just been told
could you at least pretend to be telling
me oh you did was go like this Mook
what's that book book apparently if what
Jeff Ross just muttered is true I'm told
Rob Ford's escape from rehab he's on the
loose in the Los Angeles area I think
we've got footage right now let's take a
look there he is he's running up a hill
he's headed up a hill he's headed I
think he's running towards a fence he's
climbing the fence
he dropped for his now he's a classic
he's crossing the freeway control
officers have found debris they're on
his trail this could be handled
he's my jack the bike board is hijacked
the bike and what else is he up to now
it looks like he's not he's attacking a
car he's at ten now he's headed to LA
he's only legal crack clinic he's at a
gas station he's drinking
he's in a tree I think they know they've
coupes have cornered him in a tree they
have tranquilizers this is good they got
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]